okay so you went to LA yes I did go to
LA and actually I must tell you I had
not been on a plane exactly you want to
talk about that a little bit is that
that is that was the first time either
of us had travelled since February yeah
and I wouldn't have done it if it wasn't
very important you know Joe Rogan is is
a special phenomenon and so it seemed
worth doing in light of what's going on
in the world and the opportunity to talk
about it with Joe to his audience but
the act of getting on an airplane was of
all the things that I've seen I think it
was the most different from normal
right the experience from one end of the
to the other of the airport of the
airplane everything was bizarre and
although in some ways you know the
airport was wonderfully empty at some
level it was you know it was a calmer
space and my plane Zak do you have the
video can you put the video on that I
took of my plane okay so I will show you
a video of what it was like
see very few seats are full butterfly
that would have been fun yeah this
flight would have been jams hacked on a
normal day
so anyway it's a very different and
jarring experience in as much as lots of
aspects of it the more comfortable I
have to say sense that something must
have gone very very wrong for a plane to
look like this during a normal flying
period was it just never lifts you're
constantly reminded that something is
way off
I mean you're you know you're enclosed
in your face mask yeah in fact I wore
not only my band and I were a double
face mask thinking that this was about
the most dangerous thing I had engaged
in since recirculated air yeah I cannot
escape from yeah they do say before you
get on the plane there now like these uh
screens that broadcast information tell
you that the air is HEPA filtered I
couldn't get anybody to tell me for sure
whether that was normal and they're just
telling us about it now or that's been
added nobody seemed to know but at the
moment it's broadcasting this
information and all of these things are
are and that should I mean that should
do it right this is a big virus that
should HEPA filter it filtration should
do it well if it was the virus alone it
wouldn't be enough but the fact of the
virus travels in water droplets really
the virus alone would not be caught by a
filter is that right I think that's
right very small now there isn't there
is a number I forget what the scale is
gold but so anyway also in both
directions my flight was either canceled
or the plane was changed there's a lot
that's just not functioning very well in
this system so there is that but yes I
went to LA and LA is also very off it's
just coming out of lockdown so there's
beginning to be traffic again and things
like that
but it's rather surreal out there how
bad so you want I guess I'm curious and
maybe most people wouldn't be if they
don't know la well but the idea of an LA
without traffic strikes me is not really
la you know in a much a much improved
environment but I think you know earlier
in the lockdown we were hearing that the
streets were empty and kids are playing
ball in the streets and and such and is
there is there anything else you want to
say about you know the experience of
moving through LA
as it emerges from lockdown you know the
thing is there's not very much reason to
move through it so so you just want to
where you go it's sort of you know
wherever you are you're probably
experiencing
I wish I was there with you but sangria
right are they completely free mmm I'm
not sure actually I'm not sure but yeah
you're somewhere on pause some kind of
pause and that experience varies a bit
but the weird sense of you know things
happen in one place and it can disrupt
the functioning of a city but for the
world to be this way at once it's very
strange
[Music]